Stanford University
I'm really honored to be here for the
inaugural conference on global
development in poverty and it's really
great to see students faculty and
professionals from so many disciplines
coming together to think about shared
prosperity and health you know I've been
both an infectious disease physician
working in some of the poorest places in
the world and a university president and
if he asked me which was more difficult
treating multi drug-resistant
tuberculosis in the slums of Lima Peru
or getting faculties to work together
across disciplines and big problems very
very close call that's it but that's
precisely your mission here at the
global development and poverty
initiative seeking transformative
solutions to challenges of development
in poverty that are necessarily
cross-disciplinary is exactly what a
great university should be doing this
collaborative approach to solving the
world's toughest challenges is something
that we've worked to institutionalize at
the World Bank Group because without
collaboration that is both broad and
deep we have really little hope of
accomplishing our twin goals which dean
saloner mentioned to end extreme poverty
by 2030 and boost shared prosperity to
accomplish the first we have to reduce
the proportion of people living under a
dollar ninety a day to less than three
percent we looked at this carefully and
because of natural disasters and and
other unforeseen disasters it's hard to
get it below three percent to accomplish
the second we have to grow the income to
the bottom forty percent at least as
fast but preferably faster than the rate
of growth of the economy as a whole
these goals were endorsed by all 188
member governments of the World Bank
Group in April of 2013 just about eight
months after I started and I was both
delighted and a little bit surprised
that there was such unanimity around the
goals because they're the most ambitious
in the history of the bank over my
career I've learned and it's something
that I think is very well taught in
business schools that setting time bound
targets is one of the most important
steps
if you want to achieve ambitious goals
it's true in the field of health but
it's even more true when it comes to the
health of poor people and when I was
working at the World Health Organization
in HIV we set this target get of
treating three million people in
developing countries with hiv/aids
treatment antiretrovirals by the end of
2005 and that was just two and a half
years after we established the target
now when we set the target there were
probably anywhere from 50 to 75,000
people in all of sub-saharan Africa in
treatment but probably 10 million well
at that time probably at least 2 or 3
million by the definitions of that age
needed treatment so this campaign of
getting 3 million on treatment by 2005
may not sound like much and it certainly
probably doesn't sound like much to the
undergraduate students but back then
just about the entire global public
health community told us that we were
crazy
critics told us that it couldn't be done
there wasn't enough money there wasn't
enough infrastructure some even
suggested that treatment was too complex
for African people because Africans did
not have watches and would not be able
to comply with very complicated medical
regimens but with extraordinary
commitments I mean President Bush made
one of I think the most extraordinary
commitments that I have ever witnessed a
president making when he established the
President's Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief and also we had the Global Fund
to treat AIDS for to fight AIDS TB and
malaria these huge new efforts plus the
three by five target brought together a
diverse set of actors and we stopped
spending all our time arguing about
whether treatment was possible and
focused on scaling up and unless you
have a target and somebody is counting
which is what we did at the World Health
Organization it's very hard to get
people to stop fooling around and and
and having frankly at that time what I
thought were unhelpful arguments so by
measuring success according to the
number of people being treated 3 by 5
campaign also encouraged accountability
among both donors and receive
when we announced the target both the
donors and the recipients were very
angry at us the donors were saying how
could you set such an ambitious target
when we haven't told you we're going to
give you the money and African country
ministers of health were furious because
they were saying you're setting this
incredibly ambitious target without
telling us how we're gonna get there but
by the end of 2005 the number of people
receiving HIV treatment had increased
Eightfold and we didn't reach the target
but we did reach the target in 2007 so
two years later is about the best that
the United Nations system has ever done
in in reaching a target but today I'm
almost almost 11 million people in the
region now have access to a to
antiretroviral therapy and the global
goal for 2015 is 15 million people five
times higher than what we aimed for just
ten years ago and m'm ajan for me what
Africa would look like if we hadn't
fought so hard for AIDS treatment but
you have to remember and there's a lot
of revisionist history going on but the
vast majority of the global health
community was saying treatment is
impossible for the 25 million people in
Africa living with HIV we're afraid
we're talking about the next generation
so all 25 million people we look them in
the eye global health leaders and told
them I'm sorry but you're all dead
because it's inconvenient and so you
know if you look back at economic growth
in Africa it's been growing at over 5%
even through the economic crisis that
started in 2008 I cannot imagine that we
would have seen that kind of growth if
nobody knew their status and ten million
people had died in countries all over
the continent so as with all ambitious
targets the global health community when
we set the target had to had to
fundamentally rethink what it was doing
and focus on the things that would make
the biggest difference so access to
drugs was a huge challenge because most
most of the developing countries did not
have procurement and supply chain
systems that were prepared to deal with
just a simple volume of medicines that
were going to pass through their systems
new strategies and alliances were
required drug regimens Diagnostics had
to be a
adapted to local conditions new
infrastructure had to be built and whole
new cadre of health workers had to be
trained but that's the beauty of time
bound and beauty of a time bound
ambitious target it forces you to change
I remember visiting a local health
official in South Africa right before we
started a 3x5 initiative who proudly
told me that his team had met all its
targets for the last five years I very
humbly suggested that well maybe your
aspirations just aren't high enough if
you're meeting every single target as
Paul Patel then is one of my heroes he's
a great medical doctor is one of the one
of the Guru's and in quality improvement
in health and he he said and this brings
through my mind every day every system
is perfectly designed to get the results
it's getting so if you want to do right
by the poor if you want to develop
health systems that can that can that
can do things for poor people's health
that never been done before you've got
to change and if you want to change a
system setting an ambitious target is a
great way to do it so we find ourselves
in a similar situation today with the
target of ending extreme poverty we have
the targets in place but what are we
going to have to do differently to
actually achieve something that has
never been possible before we have never
been able to see the end of extreme
poverty this is the first generation in
human history that has been able to see
that potential outcome the good news is
that we've made a lot of progress
in 1990 when the world population was
around 5.2 billion people
36% of a global population lived in
extreme poverty and back then the
definition of extreme poverty was a
dollar a day less than a dollar a day
in 2012 was 7.3 billion people so the
population has increased 12% lived in
extreme poverty in the last 15 years
we've gone from nearly 2 billion people
living in extreme poverty to less than a
billion this year for the first time in
history we expect that the extreme
poverty rate globally will drop below 10
percent around 9.6% 700 million people
this is the best news story in the world
today well we're deeply humbled by the
challenge ahead of us by 2020 half of
all the extreme poor will live in
fragile and conflict affected settings
the prospects for economic growth in
developing economies has is the lowest
today as it has been over the past
decade rising global temperatures will
have devastating impacts on poor
countries and poor people and as we saw
with Ebola major pandemics are likely to
disproportionately affect the poor
inside the World Bank Group for the past
50 years we've continued to distill and
analyze our global experience in
fighting poverty and boosting shared
prosperity and as a result our advice to
governments has evolved over time we've
taken a new look at the drivers of
progress over the last 15 years and know
that our approach also has to continue
to evolve our strategy to end extreme
poverty and boost shared prosperity
based on the best global knowledge
available can be summed up in just three
words grow invest ensure so decades of
experience have taught us that economic
growth is the primary driver of
increased personal income and poverty
reduction sustained growth requires
macroeconomic stability in the form of
low inflation manageable debt levels and
reliable exchange rates and government
policies and investments though have to
prioritize growth in the sectors that
will increase incomes of the poor not
all investments and not all growth
strategies will have that impact on the
poor the global economy as I mentioned
is now facing significant headwinds
especially for the emerging markets
growth is slower than its than it's been
for some time and you know the commodity
supercycle which is driven so much of a
developing economy economic growth has
ended three or four years ago and the
depressed commodity prices we think will
continue for some time there's also an
exodus of capital from developing
countries that's likely to accelerate as
the Federal Reserve increases its funds
rate target we nobody knows exactly when
but
it will happen soon now you know
promoting growth has always been a
priority for the World Bank Group but it
at times it has seemed that it was our
only priority other development goals
including investing in health and and
and the environment were just not on the
front burner for the World Bank Group
and that's why twenty years ago I was
part of a movement called 50 years is
enough it was a movement that was
focused on shutting down the World Bank
Group on its fiftieth anniversary
in 1994 now you know I'm very glad that
we lost that argument because I get I
get to come here and talk to you guys
but the the great thing about the World
Bank is that we've learned from evidence
we change and we're now taking a much
broader approach to development because
we know that growth in GDP alone is not
enough for us to achieve the twin goals
of ending extreme poverty boosting
shared prosperity we have been a
producer of some of that evidence that
that has forced us to change but we're
also an institution that is ready to
make changes in operations in policy
based on evidence and and I'm sure the
people in this audience know the
evidence is increasingly clear than in
addition to growing their economies
developing countries have to make
investments in their people especially
in health and education they also have
to support programs and policies that
ensure people against risks that
threaten to plunge them into poverty
because of events and circumstances
beyond their control the so called
social protection programs now among the
investments that developing countries
can make in the health and education of
the people the most important ones start
when a woman becomes pregnant it's the
combination of health nutrition and
education of investment and insurance
known as early childhood development 26%
of all children under five in developing
countries are stunted and this is a
condition in which children are not only
malnourished and under stimulated but
risk a loss of
abilities literally have fewer neuronal
connections now in sub-saharan Africa
unfortunately 36% of all children under
5 are stunted now so just to get your
head around that that's nearly 4 in 10
of sub-saharan Africa's children with
with frankly limited prospects in life
in my mind this is an absolute disgrace
it's a it's a global scandal and in my
view really something like akin to a
medical emergency children who are
stunted by age 5 will not have an equal
opportunity in life it's difficult to
imagine a path that to the end of
poverty or shared prosperity without
proper antenatal care with from others
appropriate stimulation nurturing and
nutrition for infants and young children
because if your brain won't let you
learn and adapt in a fast changing world
you won't prosper and neither will
society all of us lose the World Bank
Group is committed to effective action
on early childhood development we've
identified five packages of 25 services
for children based on strong evidence
from 2001 to 2013 we invested 3.3
billion dollars in early childhood
development programs around the world
Haiti Indonesia to make the list suit to
Mozambique Russia Vietnam using in one
example using innovative policymaking
and development finance tools that was
when I'll talk about a little bit later
giving money only when the results are
in
we helped Peru cut its rate of childhood
stunting in half from 28 to 14% in just
eight years we know that progress is
possible and progress is possible
quickly but we have to do so much more
what we need now is an ambitious global
goal that will help drive our work in
early childhood development for
childhood stunting the world did set a
target in 2012 to reduce stunting in
children 40 percent by 2025 but that
would still leave a hundred million
children stunted this goal in my view is
just not ambitious enough if equality of
opportunity is indeed a value that we
all
share and we're serious about boosting
shared prosperity we need to work
together to set a target to end the
stunting for all children well before
2030 that kind of goal will enable us to
hold each other accountable forcing us
to change the way we work we need to
formulate a plan to end stunting and use
innovative financing mechanisms to pay
for it now ensure ensuring that children
have the neuronal connections to learn
is only half the battle we've got also
make sure that they're in school and
actually learning today 91 percent of
children in developing countries attend
primary school which is up from 83
percent in 2000 so over that 15 year
period attendance rates in sub-saharan
Africa have gone up 20 percent that's
great the number of out-of-school
children a primary school age has also
fallen by almost half to 57 million from
100 million in 2000 but we cannot rest
until every child is in school and every
child is also learning the evidence on
learning outcomes unfortunately among
young people in many countries is really
very alarming an estimated 50 percent of
young people in Kenya who have completed
six years of Education cannot read a
simple sentence international
assessments also show that average
eighth grades the average eighth grade
student in the Middle East and North
Africa region performs below the
international average in science and
math and in some cases very far below
the low achievement levels that we're
seeing throughout the developing world
have devastating implications when you
when people look for jobs and also will
have devastating implications for future
economic growth I think that many of you
of course know of Sal Khan and his great
work at the Khan Academy and I think
this presents a very interesting model
for boosting educational outcome
globally much more quickly you know by
with with $25 iPad type devices and Khan
Academy instruction we can put into the
classroom some of the best instructors
in the world using technologies you know
what we found is that teachers
themselves learn
how to teach important lessons by having
the Khan Academy materials in the
classroom and so we're now working in
rural Guyana and India and also with
Mexico and Middle Eastern countries to
try to bring Khan Academy translated
into those programs because they'd have
to wait otherwise 20 to 30 years before
the quality of teachers gets up to where
it is for example in East Asia the pilot
programs we have underway are showing
that technology can potentially
transform learning outcomes in in like
in Lagos Nigeria for example eReader
czar being used to help improve student
performance and data shows that the
devices have had a significant positive
impact on students nonverbal skills and
reading and math scores efficient
especially among students who do not own
textbooks so education is an area that
we've got to move but health is the
topic of the day and the great news
again in health is that we have so much
better evidence on the role of improved
health outcomes in everything from
ending poverty but also economic growth
in 2013 The Lancet Commission on
investing in health which is a team of
global health experts led by Larry
Summers concluded that between 2000 and
2011 better health outcomes accounted
for fully 24 percent of increase in
what's called full income not just in in
it's a it's a complicated calculation
it's a great paper the Commission also
determined that the economic return on
investment in health in low and middle
income countries could be as high as ten
to one now you know even here in Silicon
Valley 10 to 1 is a pretty good
investment return so with the right
investments with the with the right
program structure we can we can reach
what they have called a grand
convergence in in health outcomes
meaning that a child in Cambodia and a
child in California could have the same
chance to survive and live a long and
healthy life
this makes improving the quality of
health systems everywhere a critical
development issue that's essential to
boosting shared prosperity so
in the calls that we've made and many
others have made on for universal health
coverage we see the potential for a
transformative program that can bring us
toward this grand convergence the
challenges are many the depth and
breadth of these challenges were never
more clear than during the Ebola crisis
we learned then that we are completely
unprepared for an epidemic the outbreak
also showed that we have failed over
many years to build effective health
systems in every country and that of
course means that the weakest health
systems are the ones that are going to
accelerate any epidemic in the future
the deaths of more than 11,000 people
and billions of dollars of economic
losses in Guinea Liberia and Sierra
Leone have proven this to us these are
three of the poorest countries in the
world but prior to Ebola these were
three of the fastest-growing economies
in the world
needless to say their economic growth
has been negative over the past few
years so we need a robust capacity to
respond to epidemics wherever they occur
and we also need the stronger health
systems that can diagnose and treat the
sick wherever they are stronger health
systems can extend the reach of nurses
and doctors and also not only not only
they've been proven time and again to
improve outcomes in so many different
areas but we can also use them as the
front lines of our epidemic outbreak
alert and response network just imagine
what would have happened if in December
2013 the small in the in the small
Guinean village where 2 year-old Emil la
mano who is the first the index case of
Ebola imagine if that village had
trained health personnel linked to a
disease surveillance system like there
already is in the Democratic Republic of
the Congo and Uganda though epidemics
outbreaks in those countries were
quickly controlled because those systems
were in place
what first looked like cholera or
diarrhea
would have been recognized as
potentially something far more serious
and a quarantine would have been
established in DRC and Uganda
instead we didn't figure out that what
was going on until three months later
when a doctor who had been treating the
the sick had died by then the infection
had spread to three countries we three
months it took us to even know what was
going on one of the most important
interventions during the fight against
Ebola was behavioral change and this was
absolutely critical local customs
dictated that people care for victims at
home and the custom also was to touch
the dead bodies before burial and that's
precisely the point at which the dead
person is most infectious the many
Western doctors and and and literally
billions of dollars that ultimately
supported the containment effort would
not have worked unless if we had not had
ultimately people who spoke the local
language who knew the local customs and
had enough cultural capital to be able
to convince people to change their
behaviors in the end it was behavior
change that stopped the epidemic now we
believe that trained community health
workers can be vital to improving
outcomes in many areas of Public Health
and also that they can form the backbone
of a community-based approach to global
pandemic response now investments in
community health workers generate lots
of other good development dividends they
offer formal employment for women and
often unemployed youth they can also
become pathways out of poverty and
informality for low-income and
low-skilled workers in India and
Ethiopia the World Bank group is
supporting programs that train frontline
health responders and give them
incentives to continue on career paths
in healthcare and other related social
sectors such as in in those two cases
early childhood development overall our
financing is expected to support and
trained close to 1 million mostly female
community health workers in the areas
that are needed the most you know
there's still so much that we need to do
to build effective global pandemic
response and just to give you a sense of
it virologist infectious disease experts
are almost certain that something like a
1918 staph flu pandemic is going
happen in the next 30 years and that
would lead to more than 30 million
deaths and anywhere from five to ten
percent of lost global GDP that's
anywhere from four to eight trillion
dollars of economic losses so why is it
that we have not yet built an effective
response well to do so first whu-oh has
to be much stronger and better resourced
we need to provide more funding for
whu-oh and put them in the position of
leadership we've got to build these
systems that I've talked about in every
country in the world and we also have to
find the incentives for appropriate
vaccine and drug development so that so
that the the the companies that can
actually make them are involved in the
process
also we need pre-arranged agreements I
got phone calls from from FedEx and from
DHL and from Vodafone saying how can we
help and because we had not pre pre
negotiated these agreements they played
almost no role indemnity for drug
companies that had vaccine candidates
had not been worked out and it took
forever to get past that we need to get
those things in place quickly also
instead of waiting we were the ones who
put the first big money on the table -
for the Ebola response but that happened
in August eight months after the first
case we need instruments that would that
will disperse in eight hours or eight
days and not eight months and so we're
now developing a concept that we've
called the pandemic emergency facility
or the that's our or the peph and the
the pandemic emergency facility is an
innovation that would disperse funding
immediately to national governments and
responding agencies to support a surge a
quick surge in capacity in the context
of an outbreak but by doing this the the
so called path the pandemic emergency
facility would eliminate the
availability of finance as a constraint
on response and you know it's still
unbelievable to me that we waited eight
months before really putting the money
on the table that was needed so we're
looking at a lot of different ways to do
this that one is for this facility to
leverage resources from Rio
and the capital markets and spurring the
creation of a whole new market for
pandemic insurance for developing
countries payouts would be immediate and
on the basis of a particular threshold
we have to come to agreement on what
those thresholds are but we're getting
there now now the thing that I like
about this is it would bring market
discipline to crisis response by
creating incentives for data reporting
and monitoring of diseases and promote
investments in pandemic preparedness
another possibility is for donors to
commit to providing funding to to
specific accounts that are already
linked to this global system but that
would only have to be paid in the
context of a real pandemic now I have to
tell you when when the pandemic is is
going forward I get calls all the time
saying oh my god this is potentially
disastrous we're willing to put any kind
of money on the table but then you have
that high level of awareness and that
awareness just drops after a few weeks
so we're in that trough where the
interest has dropped but we can't we
can't let that happen and I've promised
many people that as an infectious
disease doctor head of the World Bank I
promise that I will not let it drop and
this is why we're working on it you know
my friend Larry brilliant whom some of
you may know said that outbreaks are
inevitable epidemics are optional we
have to make sure that things like
financing things like getting making
sure the whu-oh is where it should be
and all of the different structures are
in place to improve our ability to
respond to pandemics and actually build
a system that will work the new anthems
growing Germany which hosted a g7
leaders conference asked me specifically
to come and talk about this next year we
expect to have an even greater
opportunity in Japan where the g7
leaders again have put this issue of
pandemic response on the table we've got
to put the institutional frameworks
together it's going to be complicated
but we cannot let another year or two
years go by and not have a system in
place with that with partners we're now
also trying to increase access to
financing for
for health systems and the the the the
purpose of doing that is that it's not
it's not an automatic there are the
developing countries all over the world
are facing huge constraints and so we
need to find ways of incentivizing sin
so we built something called the Global
Financing facility in which the the
donors can put in money and then we use
our own balance sheet we use our own
resources to take that small amount of
money and then multiply it at a ratio of
around one to four
so with that money we really think that
we're going to be capable for the first
time in history of building systems that
actually work you know I I want to stop
because I want to have a chance to talk
with you a little bit but let me just
give you a sense of where we are so in
in Guinea Liberia and Sierra Leone
eleven thousand people died but every
single person every single American who
was infected with Ebola and came to the
United States for treatment lived so we
heard mortality rates of Ebola eighty
percent is what we were told
but that eighty percent is only true if
you have no health system in place if
you have a system like the United States
the mortality rate was empirically zero
what does that mean for us how can we
possibly talk about shared prosperity
and ending extreme poverty when you have
that kind of inequality every single day
well what we do at the World Bank is
pretty straightforward we have a balance
sheet we do 65 billion dollars with the
business every year and one of the great
experiences for me as a medical doctor
was to finally learn what rich people do
every day to make themselves richer and
so we are now gonna take our entire
balance sheet and do everything we can
to ensure that the poorest of the poor
are getting access to those tricks those
those these fancy ways of using leverage
and and using swaps and and and
exploiting in the changes in swaps and
exposures we do so many different things
now because there is there is plenty of
money in the world to end extry
poverty and boost shared prosperity we
could do it today if we want it if we
just redistribute we could do it today
but we found that those kinds of
approaches where you equalize outcomes
haven't worked well it just simply
haven't worked well so what we're
focusing on is making the kinds of
investments that will really create
equality of opportunity and then using
our balance sheet every way possible to
make it possible to provide energy to
provide transport to provide health and
education and and get to a point where
by 2030 we will indeed be the first
generation in human history to end
extreme poverty thank you very much for
your attention I look forward to taking
your questions in just a bit
thanks very much dr. Kim is a physician
I just want to say first off that it's
completely inspirational to see you
doing the kind of things that you're
doing and so we all owe you an enormous
debt and I'd also like to thank on
behalf of the global development poverty
program seed the GSB and FSI we're
absolutely delighted to have you here is
interesting a year ago when we began
planning this conference of course a
bola was still happening and it was very
much on our minds so this is the
audience participation part I want to
invite people their microphones we want
your questions that's the that's really
the purpose of it I'm gonna kick it off
with one but please step up to the
microphones
don't ask questions I'll start calling
on you okay I haven't been in a
classroom for a while so yeah so let me
start with I was struck in when you were
talking about the the issues that you've
faced you come from a tradition and
physician with evidence-based medicine
and I wondered how evidence-based
policymaking might work but so the
question is really what are the kind of
things that you'd like to know the
answer to now to do your job that you
don't know and is it is there a way that
the research community could help with
any of these you know on one level we we
just need to know more about what's
actually happening on the ground so
there are many countries in the world
what we haven't got poverty data for the
last ten years so we just need to
collect more basic data but also you
know I'm very encouraged by some of
these randomized evaluations that have
been done
you know Jaime Sepulveda is here in the
audience and the work that they did in
Mexico showing the impact of programs
like oportunidades and others were just
you know they changed the way
policymakers think I mean you know these
were these were controversial programs
they were actually giving cash directly
to poor people and and inside the World
Bank when I got when I got there I just
couldn't believe how many studies we'd
done on these programs and I said why
have we done so much on something that
seems so straightforward you give poor
people cash you condition it on them
doing you know basic things like making
sure
the kids are fed and whatever it seems
like such a no-brainer and they told me
it's because ideologically so many
people were against it right so there
was this notion that if you give cash to
poor people it will take away the desire
to work and but it was all ideology and
so we actually did study and ask the
question do these programs take away the
desire to work and the answer was no
absolutely not
and in fact played the role of elevating
them to the point where they could begin
to see the possibility of joining a
formal labor market right so so I think
there's so many questions like this that
we need that we need to tackle you know
on the policy level getting some system
where the World Health Organization the
World Bank other parts of the UN system
the private sector country bilateral
donors are all sort of coordinated when
that sort of 1918 flu pandemic style
thing breaks out that's really hard to
figure out I mean I how do you get the
governance right on that because you
know what we found is that if you give
it to a UN or multilateral if you give
it to us we're under so much political
pressure from our member countries that
we you shouldn't trust us to give real
data on on preparedness for example so
you know can we do this by linking with
the private sector I'm not sure but
we've got to keep experimenting until we
get it right because the stakes are just
too high I mean you know you talk to
these people in the reinsurance industry
and they're just panicked about this
because they hold all of the business
disruption policies right so if a
pentamer breaks out and all these
businesses have to stop they're
essentially facing the end of their own
business because it would be it would be
catastrophic for them so the risk is so
high and yet our preparedness is so low
how do you how do you how do you build
global governance systems that would
attack those particular global public
Bad's that we just simply neglect and
climates another one very much like that
absolutely there's someone who does
infectious disease modeling I share
their concerns certainly I think we have
a question back here my name is andreas
Rocca and I work for a nonprofit called
metrics for management and I think it's
extremely laudable that the World Bank
has committed to serving the poorest 40%
of the population
part of being able to reach the school
is being able to measure it so could you
talk about how the World Bank is
measuring how its programs that are
designed to serve the poor are reaching
those poorest to quit wealth quintiles
yeah you know the the the the revolution
in in measurement has happened in a
number of different ways one of the
things that I'm most excited about
especially in the area of health is
something called the program for results
and the program for results doesn't you
know we agree on a certain package
whether it's our most concessional loans
or are sort of quote unquote more market
rate loans and then what we say is let's
agree on what the outcomes are going to
be and in the area of health for example
it's you know malaria bed nets or in the
case of stunting the the right package
of interventions to prevent stunting and
then we don't disperse until after they
show us that they have achieved a
certain result and so you know it's a it
was incredibly controversial inside the
World Bank when we started it but the
outcomes have been just astounding
really really good so it's not just even
waiting until after the program is done
to to measure it's not dispersing until
you show an outcome now we're we started
out with just 5% of our portfolio and
now we've gotten approval from our board
to go to 15% there are other things that
we do that are more sort of budget
support where we agree on a certain
number of policy outcomes we we ask them
to do certain things ahead of time
before they get the the loan and then
the loan goes into their budget and then
we follow so that certain against
certain policy changes are are are in
place but we audit every single one of
our projects and you can look at the
outcomes of every single one of our
projects on the web we've we my
predecessor Bob Zoellick opened this up
to everybody now are we measuring the
right things we're not we're not
convinced and we just made a commitment
to do household surveys every three
years for every country in the world now
it's a huge commitment it's many
hundreds of millions of dollars of a
commitment but we realize that you can't
track they see one with the thing I
learned from 3x5 is even if your numbers
are not
perfect if you have the best numbers of
anybody you can actually create rhythm
and and pressure on the system and
that's what we need to do we need to
find out where poverty is going down
where the bottom forty percent incomes
are going up and you can't do it without
household surveys so it's a huge
commitment for us but it's you know we
think it's the right thing to do
question here hello my name is galina
fedorov i'm a CEO of good lurtz
enterprise software to fight extreme
poverty and my question to you would be
we the global goals are pretty ambitious
you would say and limited resources a
lot of conflicts and in one of your
speeches previously you mentioned that
involvement of global citizens will be a
big part of that so can you tell us what
world bank is planning to do to involve
global citizens in the process yeah
well as so just on that question
specifically you know we work now with
something called the global citizens
festival movement and every year in
Central Park they have this really cool
concert with with celebrities and so
this year I was on stage Kerry
Washington from scandal which I'm
addicted to by the way because it was it
the the person who put it together as a
Dartmouth grad Shonda Rhimes anyway
Kerry Washington introduced me right and
Beyonce was on stage and I would get to
hang around with all these cool people
right and the idea is to create a global
movement in poverty now I'm not sure if
this will work but but it's fun and
and I you know I told my I have a
fifteen-year-old in a six year old and
so they thought well you know we've seen
dad with these people but now we're
working with Novak Djokovic to work on
stunting
I mean Novak is amazing I mean he grew
up in war-torn Serbia he had an
opportunity there were a lot of others
that did not and he really wants to make
a commitment so my 15 year old son
tennis player now thinks that I'm cool
because I I hang out with Novak Djokovic
and we actually sat in his box during
one of the u.s. to open tournaments my
six-year-old I at this global citizen
festival I got to appear on stage with
Big Bird right so now even my
six-year-old thinks I'm cool because I
get to hang out with Big Bird look I
don't know if I don't know if this will
happen but here's what here's what we
have to do and again what I would say to
all of you anything it's so good to be
in the business school because that's
the one thing that I regret now that I'm
the World Bank Group president is it
took me this long to really think hard
about finance right because there's so
many things that you can do if you have
a balance sheet that you wouldn't be
able to do otherwise and so with this
new sustainable development goals 117
goals 169 targets it's huge the
secretary-general asked us to come up
with a vision for how we can pay for all
of it and it's a multi trillion-dollar
agenda every year so we actually sat
back and said so what would it look like
well first you have to start off by
improving tax collection right we think
that poor countries can improve tax
collection two to four percent of GDP
that's a huge amount of money that
rivals you know the amount that is given
every year with official development
assistance right so we also if we stop
the illicit financial flows literally
people taking money and leaving or you
know companies not paying taxes in poor
countries we can also increase the
amount of money for development and then
there's there's a grant based official
development assistance there's
concessional loans there's
public-private partnerships in private
sector so we think that all together we
can find the trillions of dollars needed
to tackle this huge development agenda
but I think also young people have to
get involved you know
I don't yet see the young people's
movement around climate changes I think
we'll need in order to really wake up
and get get to below two degrees Celsius
we're not there yet and and and so so
engagement is really critical and so
that's why you'll see me with Novak and
Big Bird and everyone else yeah now we
have students I'd love to hear from some
students now he's really glad he did
here in the World Bank hi my name is
Joey noble see I'm a student the GSB I
also found our none for profit that an
Egypt that focuses on illiteracy for
primary education students where 70% of
the kids in school cannot read and write
yeah my only little interaction with
with the world bank has been a bit you
know confusing is that you know my
perception is that they're helping you
know the world and the NGOs but when I
approached the World Bank and you know
tried to get support the thing is they
they said we focus mainly with
government's yeah and we did actually
manage to get some money which is good
but the fact is I felt that there's
maybe some kind of a waiver space where
the World Bank can also try to fund and
help smaller NGOs in which they can you
know maneuver much quicker and maybe be
some kind of a connection between the
government and the people on the ground
so do you see any hope of the World Bank
kind of moving or shifting towards
working with some different NGOs on the
ground or you think just governments and
that's it well so you know we're
essentially a cooperative right a
cooperative 100 of 188 member countries
and we provide loans and so you know the
loans are based on sovereign guarantees
in other words the country themselves
guaranteed a loan so it's very hard to
do that with multiple NGOs but we even
though it's hard we've done it so we
have something called the global program
for social accountability where we
started with a small amount of money 20
million the Ford Foundation the Soros
Foundation put money in and we're
beginning to provide grants directly to
NGOs but they would they would be grants
now once we provide funding to a
government though the government can
make their own decisions about whether
they utilize NGOs or the private sector
to provide the services so at that point
Menino because it's based on a sovereign
guarantee we have to go through
governments for the private the public
sector side we also have a huge private
sector practice where we make loans to
companies that want to work in
developing countries but also we take
equity positions in those companies as
well so if you have a a private sector
company that's trying to solve some
major problem in a developing country
come talk to us because you know once
again you know we have a very strong
triple-a rating and we can provide
financing for real on relatively good
terms but even more important than the
financing that we provide if you come to
us and the the private sector group is
called the International Finance
Corporation IFC and IFC invests in your
company it's almost like a seal of
approval and then it's much much easier
to crowd in other investors to get to
get your company up and running so that
that's just simply the way we work in
the way we've been invented yeah over
here hi my name is Muhammad and I'm a
student in the master of Development
practice put them at UC Berkeley I've
had a lot of stuff that both you and
Paul Farmer have written about partners
and health and the main two takeaways
that I had from that with that a glass
fit approach is really important and
secondary that the approach that you go
into one community with cannot just be
taken and applied to another community
so I'm wondering with your work at the
World Bank which is very top-down and
kind of tries to take economic policies
and apply them across developing country
how have you been able to work inside
all these points of view well you know
first of all the question is what do you
mean grassroots I mean it's it's a
complicated question I have to tell you
that if you were to say to me that the
the our biggest impact has been on
things like multidrug-resistant TB and
HIV because we changed fundamentally the
way people thought about it and you know
none of those ideas came to us
necessarily from the community I mean
they didn't come and say we really think
you should treat multi drug-resistant TB
second line antibody that's not that's
not how they think about those things
and so they're there for me the front
most fundamental takeaway from partners
in health is that we started with a very
clear ethical moral principle which was
to make a preferential option for the
poor and then from there we said so
given that our goal is to make a
preferential option for the poor what is
it that we should be doing as medical
doctors as people who live in in in
wealthy countries and the conclusions
were kind of unexpected right and and I
I know what you're saying and many
people come to us and say well you
should only do what what the people want
you to do in a particular community but
I've worked in so many communities and
sometimes the people in those
communities can see exactly what they
want in that then and that's what you do
but I think what we've done is to say
okay we can't do everything we can't
we're not going to do a feeding program
everywhere we go what we'll do is to try
to look at a particular problem and
engage with you and say here's what
we're seeing what are you seeing and
then once that process of engagement
happens you come together to a
conclusion about what is to be done
which is exactly what we do at the World
Bank Group we do our own analysis of
what any country needs to do in order to
grow its economy invest in its people
ensure that poor people don't fall back
into poverty but then once we do our
analysis we take it to the country
themselves and it's usually ministers of
finance and others and say and also
civil society now participates much more
than before what is it that you think
your priorities are and then if we can
come to an agreement then we go forward
so I you know I've heard this before you
know you're top-down and we're you know
let me just put it this way so I don't
think my philosophy the notion of a
preferential option for the poor has
changed one bit since I've worked in the
slums of Lima and in rural Haiti I just
have 65 billion a year I can put to it
now right so you know why do you think
that eight months after I took the job
we established a goal of ending extreme
poverty because it's the ultimate way of
expressing your notion your belief in a
preferential option for the poor which
is which is which is the foundation of
everything
Partners in Health so the World Bank
Group this great huge institution
endorsed this notion of a preferential
option for the poor
eight months after I took over so now
everything we do I can go back and say
okay fine I understand that but how's
that gonna help us end extreme poverty
in the world and because I can ask that
question over and over and over again
inside the World Bank Group it's
actually changing what we do so you know
I Partners in Health continues to do
this great work by tackling seemingly
intractable issues in the poorest
communities and now my job at the World
Bank is to take those insights like what
I talked about today community health
workers and scale it up right that's
what we do we do scale we take great
innovations that come from the
grassroots and take them to scale
question over here hi I'm Tom and I'm
from the Stanford daily the student
newspaper here you recently wrote about
your experience as a migrant and spoke
about the importance of tackling the
refugee crisis so my question is how
would the World Bank make sure or at
least encourage individual countries to
develop concrete domestic institutions
to tackle these crises it's a great
question you know the the article I
wrote was in the context of a report we
put out we do something called the
global monitoring report and this year
or this particular issue was on
demographics and what we showed was that
in a lot of advanced economies their
aged population is increasing their
working population is shrinking and
their birth rates are low so for them
the most important thing that they can
do in many ways from the perspective of
economic growth in the medium and long
term is to attract migrants right and I
said I've said many times it's
xenophobia turns out to be a terrible
economic policy for advanced economies
now that was taken out of context I was
accused of calling you know certain
countries in a folk which I was not but
there's so much great evidence now that
suggests to us that xenophobia is a bad
economic strategy
sexism is a terrible economic strategy
you know South Korea has the lowest
female participation in the workforce of
any OECD country and you know you can
actually measure how many percentage
points of GDP they would increase if
they just set up a social structure that
women could participate in the workforce
it turns out that ages of not listening
to young people is a terrible economic
strategy because young people are coming
out the digital world completely
differently so what we're trying to do
is put that evidence in front of our
member countries right that xenophobia
is a bad strategy sexism is a bad
strategy
you know marginalization inequality
we've got lots of data now that very
high levels of inequality actually slows
economic growth so all these things that
I used to proclaim not based on evidence
and only because we thought it was the
right thing to do it turns out that now
we have evidence that suggests it's
economically also the right thing to do
isn't that great
I mean III I yes I think that's just
that that's great and so but it's not
simple and so one of the things we're
doing is we're trying to create
employment opportunities for Syrian
refugees in Jordan and how do you do
that because it's you know where's the
money going to come from so we're
working with the UK with the European
Union and the Jordanian government to
try to create very specific employment
projects for Syrians but also for
Jordanians so if we can find a way to go
out and raise a bond but then have the
UK buy down the interest and then open
up European markets you know
preferential access access to European
markets with the you know for for the
products made in these little projects
we could actually create a level of
stability and employment for refugees
that that would not otherwise have
happened if we would sort of stayed in
our own boxes so we're looking across
the Middle East into Africa to find much
much better ways of dealing with
refugees the fundamental point is we
have separated political negotiation
humanitarian response and development
for ever and we are now saying we can't
do that anymore we have to bring all of
those to
and think about how do you in you know
prior to a conflict happening how do you
think about regional development
initiatives that might actually lower
the possibility that a conflict reader
erupt and that you'd have to mount a
humanitarian response not easy but we
we've got you know the the standard
approaches worked so poorly for so long
that we're going to try all kinds of new
things with that unfortunately we're
going to have to close the please join
me in thanking dr. kam talk
Stanford University
you